Now that you know about stop words, I'm going to show you how to get a list of
stop words out of a Python package called NLTK, which stands for
the natural language tool kit.
In this demonstration, I'm going to be using the interpreter.
At the end of this video, there will be a quiz, and
I want you to do the quiz on your own laptop, not in the Udacity web browser.
So this quiz is a little bit different.
So, let's get started.
I fire up the interpreter.
To get the stopwords out, I have to import them from NLTK.
I found this line of code in an example when I went to Google looking for
how to get stopwords from NLTK.
To get a list of stopwords, say something like sw equal stopwords.words.
And then as a parameter to words,
I have to tell it what language I am interested in.
That's English.
And [LAUGH] if you are using NLTK for
the first time like I am on this computer you'll get an error because NLTK
needs to have a corpus from which it gets the stopwords.
The corpus is just a body of documents.
So in order to fix this, I have to call this nltk.download function.
You have to make sure NLTK is imported first, and
then what we need is the corpora and then we hit download.
This will take a few minutes.
And now that that's finished, I can try again.
Much better.
So I can go into this sw list and I can ask what some of the stock words are.
So the first one in the list, is the word i.
That makes sense, people like to talk about themselves a lot.
Let's find out what the tenth one is.
Yours.
Again, makes sense.
What I want you to do
in the quiz now is to repeat these steps that I went through.
So, use your Python interpreter to actually download the corpus and
to get the list of stop words out.
And here's my question for you.
How many stop words are in the list?
Write your answer in this box